I had a woman once after a show she goes
I liked your set but I can't tell if
you're right or left and I was like good
that's a good thing I'm just being funny
I don't know if I want to take this
mantle of like truth saying comedian
you're a prophet you got to get out
there and say the truth for the people
I'm like oh I got like dick jokes that's
the other thing that's annoying it's
like not only should this stop it should
cease to exist yeah you're like well
that's a little trumpy that's a little
uh fascisty or whatever
it doesn't feel like it's really about
justice as much as it is about the joy
of ruining and taking down somebody
that's what was the most Sinister part
of it that's the other ironic thing it's
like defund the police but this they're
very police-like you know hey don't say
this don't do that you got out of line
we gotta hit you over the head it's very
police-like we cater to that one queef
who was upset about the wheelchair joke
and like I've seen stuff where they're
like no fat jokes and a guy's like I'm
400 pounds my whole Act is Fat Jokes
you're trying to be Progressive and a
good guy but you're telling me what I
can't say what makes me feel better how
I get over my pain this is how I relieve
you know I feel better with with the
jokes and they're like yeah it's no good
it's like
so you're like a dictator
Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
pleasure I get from the locals is when
we share an intimate moment as we watch
a Japanese tourists get trapped in a
tube door
that is good but I wasn't talking about
their locals I was talking about our
community on locals you mean the one
where you get phenomenal behind the
scenes content when you the ideal space
when you get wasp incredible guests like
Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein Bill
Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla Heather
Hein and others your questions not just
that you can get supporter only benefits
like trigonometry mugs monthly calls
with our other top supporters and even a
regular meal with me and Francis you
also get phenomenal behind the scenes
footage of our trip to America where we
met a whole host of incredible guests
and gave ourselves terminal indigestion
we're also starting to do monthly
giveaways for locals only the first one
will be signed copies of Andrew doors
new book plus you get access to an
incredible community of like-minded
people who share means have fun
conversations and most importantly you
get to make new friends you can support
us with as little as seven dollars or
about five pounds a month or give us
more for the higher tier benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
hello
and welcome to trigonometry on the road
from the USA I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitchen and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our brilliant
guest today from the New York leg of the
trip is a fantastic comedian Mark
Normand he's looking around for welcome
to trigonometry brother hey good to be
here I said before it looks like the
game of Clue this is so nice and the
chair is great I mean this is a sweet
pad yeah well thank you to our Anonymous
supporter who let us stay here and use
this space we're big fans of his he
knows who he is Jeffrey Epstein
exactly back from the dead
but listen man it's good to have you on
the show you're crushing it at the
moment uh you're a brilliant comic for
those people in our audience you're not
familiar with you who are you how are
you where you are what's been your
journey through life sure I'm a stand-up
comedian out of New York City I've been
doing it for 16 years or so but on
multiple shows and whatnot and uh
currently on the road like crazy trying
to get an hour together multiple
podcasts you've seen me on the rogans
the tonight shows you name it Netflix
and uh it's nice to be here with you
chaps this is great I want to have sex
with you this place is so uh well you
take on that yeah jump on board brother
all right well I'll pop that Hyman
but this place just gets you horned up I
want to get a bottle in here and do Coke
off her ass anyway that's enough about
our producer that's good man it's good
it's lovely to have you on Mark so how
is it like what's what's the comedy
scene like at the moment how has it been
after the craziness of the past few
years has it returned to normal I think
so yeah I think we're back I think
people need comedy I think it's uh it's
actually helped comedy because let's be
honest you know a lot of [ __ ] got weird
with the pandemic political and this and
that and I think there's a big divide in
what the media and news is saying or
like when Biden comes out and says a
Thing versus what everyone's actually
feeling and I think comedy slid right
into that Gap and fisted it you know I
think a lot of that's why comedy's so
popular right now podcasts are so
popular yeah because everybody's like
this I get you know like listening but
when Biden's like hey check it out gas
prices drop this and that and then you
go check and they haven't dropped so
you're like well that's weird then a
comet goes out there and he's like hey
these gas prices are higher than Hunter
Biden it's like yeah yeah that's true
and I think that's where comedy and
podcast slid in and that's why they're
so popular yeah yeah and
and look there's a lot of people talking
about this particularly in the UK
there's a problem like you know with
freedom and speech and comedy you can
say this but you can't say this if you
make this joke you're going to be
canceled you know you're someone like
who's doing phenomenally well what's
your take on all this well I think it's
uh a little bit of a bummer you know
because there's two there's two camps
one like an Andrew Schultz you know
funny guy comedian he's like this all
this outrage is great because then we
get to say crazy [ __ ] and everybody
loves it and it's hugely popular and you
make a bunch of money which is true but
when it gets scary is when we have this
Society set up where nowadays bigger
being called a bigot is like the worst
thing can be called and you could lose
your job or or some kind of whatever is
ostracized from society be labeled and
then you become radioactive so I hate
when they go hey you can say whatever
you want I get to say whatever I want
that's free speech I'm like yeah I get
it but I was making a joke about gay
people or whatever and from no place of
hate just whatever and then you call me
a homophobe but you don't know me so I
was making a joke you're directly
attacking me and
casting these uh you know bigoted things
onto me that I'm not so it's not really
the same so you're kind of trying to
ruin my life where I was making a joke
and then you're the hero you're the good
guy at the end of this like this dude or
lady comedian is like losing their job
and
homophobic and you're like but that's
just what you assumed and you don't even
know me so that part is where I get
pissed yeah and it's this remarkable
thing that's happened in the last few
years where people take jokes and take
them as a literal statements of facts
that's crazy Morgan Murphy funny
comedian she tweeted once before Twitter
I didn't know my jokes had answers
that sums it all up you know you're like
yeah yeah and then Bill Burr has that
great moment he's on a Morning Show and
they saw a show last night and they're
questioning him like I gotta say didn't
you think the uh Catholic joke pedophile
jokes were uh a little far and he goes I
think the priest went a little too far
you're attacking the guy making the joke
not the guy diddling right and that's
where we're at yeah well we've sort of
bought into this idea the words are like
really important yes yes and actions you
know actually like if you're if you're
attacking people and trying to end their
careers because they said some words
you're the [ __ ] good guy right right
well it's very easy to attack through
your computer and I actually have to do
anything yeah and it's like uh it's like
the WNBA it's so unfair Texas then
you're like well then go to the games go
support them but you'd rather [ __ ] and
moan about how everybody's evil uh
except for you
so uh yeah I think you made an
interesting point before we started
though which was you actually feel
completely free to say what you think on
stage with a microphone yeah it's once
you get on social media yes that
actually your freedom is restricted yeah
yeah because you know they some guy or
gal owns Instagram so it's up to them
it's a private thing which also gets
murky because they're like hey uh Trump
or Marjorie Taylor green you're off
Twitter you're you're causing whatever
your your opinions are damaging or mean
so you're off Twitter and everybody goes
well that's [ __ ] up what happened to
free speech and they go well it's a
private company they can do whatever
they want they're like well tell that to
the bakery that wouldn't sell a gay cake
how come they can't do what they want
you know and I'm not saying you
shouldn't sell a gay cake but I'm saying
you got mad at them and so now they're
mad at you basically you're both the
same and you don't even realize that
you're mirroring each other and you're
[ __ ] extremists and uh you know it's
I think it's a big cause of modernity we
have so much now
you know like we used to be scared we
used to have raids in uh classrooms
where they'd play this noise and then
you all got onto your desk because the
Russians might be bombing when that's
going on you're not worried about
pronouns you know you're like [ __ ] we
couldn't be bombed right now and now we
have Shooters and we're still like can
you believe that he said [ __ ] in 1978.
we just it's just we got it pretty good
now we got ubereats yeah you just sit at
home and get food delivered and shoved
in our fat faces and so we're like hmm I
need something I need to like get my
blood pumping hey this guy uh is in
blackface in the 40s you know sorry I'm
rambling no the rambling is good okay
yeah no it's I I think there's there's a
lot to be said for that the fact that
you know people get upset by jokes yeah
like before the pandemic I was doing you
know gigging six nights a week on the
London circuit doing all these big clubs
and I remember like I started to get
curious about all of this stuff and I
remember asking all the club Owners in
London going have complaints gone up
every single one of them said yes by a
huge amount that's interesting you know
what has happened that people listen to
a joke and suddenly go not only do I not
like it which is your right it's your
right not to laugh absolutely it is but
it's also their right to go and demand
that that person not be booked again at
a club or not have or just not say that
joke right right yeah that's the other
thing that's annoying it's like not only
should they start but should cease to
exist yeah you're like well that's a
little trumpy that's a little uh
fascisty or whatever like you're this
dictator hey get rid of it it's it's
offensive but like to who and then then
we do this thing where I'll do like a
black room and it kills the jokes kill
then I'll do a white room and they're
like that's offensive to black people
I'm like well tell the uh 200 people the
black people laughing man that's exactly
what I found like I used to have a bunch
of jokes about me having dark skin and
and people think talking I'm from
Pakistan and all of that [ __ ] and he was
always ethnic minority rooms where that
went down really well yeah and it was
always the guilty white people
exactly every time so isn't that a
little [ __ ] up you're speaking for
them it's this weird soft racism hey
they can't handle that that's a little
over the line whatever and you're like
they've been through so much and you're
worried about this joke about not being
able to swim you know what are we doing
here yeah so there's a lot of uh a lot
of weird soft bigotry of like
we'll handle this they're brown yeah let
us do it and you're like well how come
that's not offensive yeah but then Megan
the joke was and I think the joke thing
to your point is just I think it's a
young generational thing I think younger
people maybe they're they're they grew
up with this online outrage and like we
got to stop this we got to stop that and
so then they see it in real life and
they weren't ready for it they're like
whoa I can't believe it we should do
something you know because everybody's
living on a pillow right now you know
and so when you go out into the real
world and hear a joke about [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
it's hot it's heavy it's like whoa I
didn't see that coming and you can't
pick what a comic says everything else
in life is Catered now Tinder it's like
oh that ugly fat tall gay whatever even
your meal I don't want uh gluten dairy
whatever but then you go to a comedy
show and it's all fresh and you're like
whoa I didn't I didn't pick this but and
you don't have control you don't have
control they like control these people
can play and they like control and we've
always had these people sure but it
definitely has upped but we've never
given them a megaphone before that's
right that too yeah and not only do we
they not have a megaphone but now we
listen yeah we cater to that one queef
who was upset about the wheelchair joke
and like I've seen stuff where they're
like no fat jokes and a guy's like I'm
400 pounds my whole Act is fat jokes and
they're like yeah but he's like so now
you're trying to be Progressive and a
good guy but you're telling me what I
can't say what makes me feel better how
I get over my pain this is how I relieve
you know I feel better with with the
jokes and they're like yeah it's no good
it's like
so you're like a dictator like I can't
do my own fat this is my Act that's
crazy yeah and what these people don't
seem to understand is that
it's by joking about these things it's
cathartic yes it actually brings us
together yeah absolutely like you
we've got the darkest sense of humor
always the people yeah who work like you
know if you've ever been out with Medics
those people it's a sense of humor is
[ __ ] up I'm like I'm look that's too
dark for me yes yeah teachers yeah HR
people you hang out with an HR person
you're doing heroin I mean they go all
in they were in a clan Hood at home and
all kinds of stuff so like it always
look at Cosby that's the inverse of that
you know I'm the America's dead you know
sweater Family Man pull your pants up
meanwhile off hours
it's a spike drink pants down yeah yeah
you get it but the thing is it's so true
the thing is and this that really pisses
we're on Ryan Long's podcast and and we
made the same point which is
when did Comics start censoring other
Comics yeah that hurts that hurts
because you know what we're doing you
know Shane Gillis for example he got in
trouble for saying uh Asian racial slur
in a podcast as a joke and they went
hard on them and you're like in the it's
so sad to see the comics tweeting
because you're like you know what he's
trying to do yeah he's not a bad guy
he's not a racist like that really I get
the soccer mom or the the religious
weirdo and you're like all right you you
know you you guys but the the comics
that that's when I was like oh things
are different now yeah man that was the
thing that totally shocked me realizing
that actually certainly in the UK
a lot of comedians are on board with
this and you actually find a lot of them
are at the Forefront they're actually
[ __ ] they're at the front with the
flag yeah that hurts yeah I thought we
were a group right I thought we were
like there was some camaraderie here but
uh once that happens that's when I got
scared I was like oh geez I've said
crazy [ __ ] to comedians because I
thought that's what we did you know the
Holocaust that wasn't real you know and
now you do that the wrong guy and you're
like he's he goes out and he goes so
Mark Norman doesn't think oh and you're
like wait what yeah that's the that's
why it's a joke because it's so crazy
but but this is what you this is what
happens in green rooms right so
everybody's just trying to outdo each
other ridiculous outrageous [ __ ] ever
and that was supposed to be the thing
that that's kind of the bond right in
many ways like the comedy club is such a
a beautiful space to be that's one of
the things I really liked about stand-up
is you've got people from every
background and there's something they've
got in common that overrides anything
yes which is we've all been on stage
we've all we've all done this thing
we're right right and part of it is the
dark sense of humor that comedians tend
to share backstage of course of course
and then to have someone backstage who
could be a bad guy you're like well this
is scary again like now I feel like I've
been I'm hanging out in the teacher's
lounge right you know where we used to
all just be [ __ ] up student you know
play around people and now it's like can
I say this around him is he gonna have
tickets here so it's a bummer it's a
bummer and those people are rarely funny
you know so it almost seems like there's
some weird way for them to like win
again like I'll take you down funny guy
and I'll be up and you're like all right
[ __ ] do you think we exaggerate this so
at some point like are you restricted in
doing comedy yourself do you feel that
you are having to not say certain things
and not make certain jokes a little uh
but I've I've luckily been doing this
long enough that I've kind of cultivated
my own people like when I do shows I
have random openers and they'll be like
dude your crowd is awesome I can't do
this [ __ ] over here right I'm like yeah
yeah it took a while but I got my people
by putting out [ __ ] on my page and my
YouTube and all that so I used to for
sure when you're the new guy you gotta
play ball you gotta kind of get in line
and find your people and kill but not
offend anybody and then eventually you
graduate to I mean look at like a Bill
Burr or Ricky Gervais yeah or Chappelle
can say whatever they want and sure
people don't like it but just don't go
see them yeah that's what I don't get
like I do think there are people who go
oh comedy it's this place I can say the
n-word and scream it out and I'll be
safe because it's protected by the rules
of comedy and free speech and you're
like yeah yeah but you're still being a
dick and just saying crazy [ __ ] to say
crazy [ __ ] I still think it has to be
funny and I still think if you do say
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
you won't have a career right well you
might get some weirdo you know fans that
are like psychos they're like that's my
guy he says what I'm thinking and you
can have them so I think they punish
themselves because a lot of people are
worried like if you give out free speech
and protect these comedians they'll just
say like white supremacy [ __ ] which you
know could happen but that person is
gonna have they're never gonna be
nobody comedians is the white
supremacist Community produced not a lot
right but it depends who you're asking
yeah that's true
hey Constantine do you want better
mental health I'm from Russia we don't
have mental health so how do you deal
with mental health you drink Vodka then
go out and wrestle bear if you leave you
feel better if you die you're not real
men what about the Bear's feelings it's
Russian Bear it has no feelings people
don't always realize that physical
symptoms like headaches teeth grinding
and even digestive issues can be
indicators of stress and let's not
forget about Doom scrolling not sleeping
enough sleeping too much under eating
and overeating sleeping too much under
eating this is Western disease therapy
has really helped me in my life to
concentrate and focus it's really
important to have someone impartial who
you can talk to about the tricky issues
that you're struggling to deal with
therapy has played a really important
role in helping me to deal with my ADHD
and become better in all areas of my
life why is he telling them how weak he
is drink Vodka feel better better help
is customized online therapy to offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to trigonometry funds get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com forward
slash trigger especially if they're not
real men that's b e t t e r h e l p.com
slash trigger
I guess what I'm saying as well is this
is your point that you made so well is
comedy is very self-regulating yes a
comedian even some deluded weirdo that
went on stage and said the n-word they
would very quickly find out yes that is
not what the audience is there for
exactly in our society now that's the
thing that's why I don't understand a
lot of these like ideas about we've got
to restrict comedy because otherwise
everyone's going to be out there
dropping the emblem because they ain't
they ain't because little police itself
right that's what happens the crowd
won't laugh the book is one book you is
just that's how that works exactly but
but you what you're saying is also very
true which is the people who are super
successful you don't have to like that's
why people go well there's no problem
with free speech and comedy look at
Ricky Gervais look at yeah there is a
free speech if you're Ricky gervation
but you've got to get there and so as
you were the new guy you felt you had to
you know make sure you didn't cross too
many lines sure sure I would go this
happened me with a black guy that's into
a white guy you know just to get by you
know and uh even now I'll have a joke
about a black guy my car got stolen I
caught the guy a black guy whatever so I
bring that up in the jumper like that's
[ __ ] up but I'm like that's what
happened get mad at reality or get him
out of that guy he's stealing my car
like right I'm just painting a picture
with the joke and feels like why does he
have to be black I'm like well I can use
this later for a joke setup you know
it's it's comedy I'm trying to set
something up here yeah and you need all
the details for the joke to work so it's
just [ __ ] like that like I have school
shooting jokes and people like what do
you promote school shootings and I'm
like no they happen so I write about
them that's it they stop trying to read
into this evil [ __ ] and that's what
really bugs me about the canceling or
whatever you want to call it is it
doesn't feel like it's really about
justice as much as it is about the joy
of ruining and taking down somebody
that's what was the most Sinister part
of it it's not really about it's like we
got one yeah it's not about it feels
like hot like sport hunting right like
if you shoot this buck and eat it I get
it but if you just shoot this buck and
walk away that's pretty [ __ ] up and
that feels like with the cancel [ __ ]
sometimes is like we got this guy we got
this guy and you're like but what did
that do yeah it did you just ruined it
and you feel better because your life is
sad and you're bankrupt of any Joy so
you ruin someone else and maybe you give
you a jolt of happiness for a second but
you're not the good guy you're you're
you're mean as [ __ ] that's so scary and
gross and yet they like to present
themselves as being incredibly virtuous
whales are literally ruining people's
lives and careers I know they hold up
the the dead animal and they go look
this was me I got it and I think
eventually it comes out in the wash like
I know a lot of people who've been that
guy who called out whatever people and
now their lives of a couple years go by
and you realize you have nothing to
offer you're just talentless and
everything fizzled away once you know
[ __ ]
simmer down a little bit so there is
that but I don't know like the name in
the name of good is like look it's good
we got the Harveys The Cosby's the epsy
these guys are all horrific and whatever
monsters but like these little ones like
you hear I I have a friend he's like a
CEO of some company not comedy and he
was at a meeting with all his employees
and he goes how are the numbers on that
whatever sale Vicky and she goes
great we got the sale and he goes that a
baby yeah all right we got it whatever
two days later HR goes
Vicky's got a problem she's she's upset
uh he's like wow what happened he goes
you called her baby and he's like well I
was saying like that a baby yeah you
know like an expression and they were
like yeah you said baby and he's like
this is my company what the hell is
going on and then you're like should I
fire her well she might sue me and then
she might write an article you know
you're like what are we doing the
company's going great and we got to deal
with this [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like it's
not even reality anymore yeah and then
you tell people about and they roll
their eyes but then you're like well
tell that to the internet when she posts
the whatever and then here we are yeah
and I get it women go through hell and
this sexual harassment and all that that
stuff does exist but it's like we gotta
be uh realistic here we gotta live in
some sort of
normal world where you can't just take
this baby I don't know it's just uh it's
just sad that that's how we're living
like we have to sidestep over these
retards who are like oh you said this
you're like I know but shut the [ __ ] up
and that's where they we need that
Russian bomb raid to come in you know
like oh you called me baby boom the bomb
comes down you're like that's what you
were worried about you ever seen that
old meme where the guy's laying in bed
and he's like I wish I had tweeted more
because he dies and you're like what are
we doing we got one life we're wasting
it on this horseshit yeah do you know
what it is like you're saying we don't
live in the real world anymore and
there's such a profound point because
with the internet yeah no one lives in
the real world anymore right right but
the problem is the internet can have
repercussions into the real world
exactly you know exactly so it starts to
feed back and now what the culture that
was created on the Internet is now
protecting people in the real world yeah
right do you do you find that this is it
it the upside I suppose is it gives you
something to push back against with your
comedy do you talk about it or you just
try and just be funny I try to talk
about it on the same level that it
actually affects real people right
because I go all over the country poor
Middle America whatever you want to call
it yeah South north and these people
have a lot less to do with the internet
that we're reading and looking at you
know we're pretty consumed with this
because we have to be we're in this
world podcast and comedy yeah whatever
they're not they're raising their kids
they're mowing the lawn they're going to
work they hate their boss their mom is
sick you know all this [ __ ] and soccer
practice whatever it is and uh I don't
think they're reading about every little
thing and every canceling and all this
so like I only do it I just skim the
surface of it just so they'll understand
because they're not as deep into it as
we are and sometimes I think we do let
this [ __ ] affect us and we absorb it too
much and it definitely makes us all sad
and crazier and angrier but uh I only
tap into it the part that affects them
yeah I think that's very wise because
like you said with marinating in this
whole culture yes and particularly
comedians you know we I don't know why
we're well I've got a few theories what
we seem to be at the cold face of this
crap
you know because we've all seen our
industry change yeah right the way from
when we started to where we are now
we've seen it sort of slowly seep in so
I think we we're affected by it more
than anything more than most people but
here's the thing do you think
we're more affected by it because of the
industry that we're in or do you think
we're the canary in the coal mine like
what's going to happen with our industry
is going to seep into all the others
uh interesting well they people keep
telling me like ah it's changing I can
feel it changing like Netflix not
getting rid of Chappelle Spotify not
getting rid of Rogan like these are all
good signs you know but to me what blows
my mind and that's a great question and
uh here's my answer I don't know if I
want to be the canary like I just want
to be a funny guy I got 12 minutes on
farting you know like I don't know if I
want to take this mantle of like truth
saying comedian you're a prophet you got
to get out there and say the truth for
the people I'm like oh I got like dick
jokes you know I'm not like this uh save
the world guy because if I do that then
I'm just as bad as these psychos in my
own in my version I'm like I don't want
to they're they're trying to save the
world by taking down comedy specials and
racism and all this and you're like
that's great go go March go protest but
I just don't want to I just want to do
my work and be left alone yeah that's my
thing so maybe we are the Canary in the
coal mines but I don't know if I want to
be that guy and not in a selfish way I
just never was I grew up watching Ellen
Seinfeld Chris Rock and
you just told funny jokes so then you
got famous and Rich and you had a good
life and that's all that's what I was
hoping for you know I
don't change the world or whatever and
look at my hat if things happen to
change because of comics and whatever
that's great but I don't know we want
that responsibility because that's a
dangerous road to go down if you do but
I made such a good point about this he
said if comedy could change the world
and change genuinely change the way that
people thought about the world they
would have banned it they wouldn't allow
it
oh yeah and it would have happened by
now yeah it's been comedy this whole
time and shit's still [ __ ] up yeah see
where I disagree with that is in Russia
where I'm from that is exactly what they
did they banned comedy wow so they
obviously think it works
I think of us of comedians more as
icebreakers yeah you know like when
there's a fight at the dinner party the
little kid goes like my diaper is soiled
and everybody goes Ah that's funny
because it's just so out of left field
but uh I think if it's as icebreakers we
we might tap into it and say something
crazy that we're all thinking and say
the truth and everybody laughs
and then people mistake that for like
aha he's a he's a soothsayer this guy's
Nostradamus he sees things that we're
all seeing but we he pinpointed it and
I'm like I don't know about that I was
just trying to cut the tension yeah you
know yeah it's it's really interesting
because the role of the comedian I think
has changed a lot yeah you know whereas
before you know we just used to go and
watch Comedy and the comedy that you
used to watch was a comedy you used to
watch right but now everything has
become political because of that
internet culture so yeah everything has
become political even comedy and it's
like if a comedian isn't political
it's starting to look a bit weird you
know what I mean I guess but I'm not
political yeah but they still try to put
you in a box they go what is I had a
woman once after a show she goes I liked
your set but I can't tell if you're
right or left and I was like good that's
a good thing I'm just being funny yeah
and why are you sitting there trying to
pinpoint it just enjoy the [ __ ] show
you crazy Coos yeah what are we doing
here yeah this isn't a a debate or
anything like what are we oh where is he
at like just watch watch the [ __ ]
show but that's the problem the internet
has made everything political right
every art form political everything is
woke anti-woke or whatever else that we
just get infected we get infected and if
you pick a side you tend to do better
this is what we always say because we
talk about these issues a lot
um and in the current climate it's the
Le it's the work left trying to cancel
people on the right and to work left
shutting down free speech so people then
go oh well you must be on the right and
that would be the best thing for us to
do financially yes to go we are
conservative we're not right but we
could do that and we'd have a [ __ ] ton
more fans and a [ __ ] ton more money
because then we'd be playing to a team
yes whereas we're much more interested
in doing what you're talking about which
is going like
I don't want to pick a team yeah I I
didn't I I never wanted to be on a team
no no I want to be a comp team comedy
right well it's exactly so that's when
it started and now that we're doing the
show that for me that's the primary
thing I don't want this show to be on a
team either right because both teams are
going to be in power at one point and
they both need challenging they both
need questioning right that that to me
is the role of people in our space
whether it's comedy whether it's
podcasting yeah but it's as you say it's
much easier to pick a team yeah yeah and
it's tempting obviously because the
money rolls in and the fans roll in but
it's I think you got to stay the course
and have some integrity and be the thing
you are at when you first started you
know like just be that guy all the way
and if you tend to gravitate and skew
from certain groups so be it but you
don't change yeah I I'm my friend Joe
list is a he's a pretty political guy
and he's he always says he's a 90s
liberal because he's like I don't
understand what's happening with the
left and he's like I'm still a liberal
but I'm like old school I like free
speech I like uh you know gay marriage
and weed and a little less government
and a little more help the people and
whatever and I'm like yeah that's what I
am but it's almost become an insult be
like oh you're one of these right wing
guys like it's kind of like we do with
racists you know like oh you're a race
is like wait what what are you crazy
like back in the the 90s you call
somebody a racist it was like what do
you oh did he kill a black guy what
happened is he like this or that and now
it's like ah races let me read the
article you know completely taking the
teeth out of that word and that's an
important word so it's it's what they
try to do to Rogan as well it's like he
he has some conversations with people he
wants to know about the vaccine whatever
he's anti-vaxx he's far right and it's
like and then he's like I voted for
Bernie Sanders I'm this I'm that they're
like yeah whatever you're far right
you're like well if we're not gonna
listen this is scary yeah you know like
Bill I keep bringing a bill but I'm a
fan but he did a a Grammy award show and
he introduced a Latin artist and the
name was all super latiny and he [ __ ]
it up and he's not a good reader
I can't say this name not only Natalie
what
all right uh
and the winner the Grammy goes to
Natalia lafourcade
[Music]
dude you oh I will look oh sorry I will
accept on behalf of her if I butchered a
name I'm sorry
and they're like he's over these white
men with the races uh mispronouncing the
name and and one guy was he's not a
racist and they go [ __ ] he always racing
goes well you know his wife's black and
the guy I wrote back like well some
people marry black women for a fetish
and that's and his wife eventually wrote
back and wrote shut up [ __ ] this black
woman had to be like shut the [ __ ] up
what are you doing
you can't even we no one can go ah good
point you got me there that's out so if
discussion is out we're really doomed
yeah and I think that's what's happening
it's just about win-win-win you know
that point you made about him not being
good reader such a good point because uh
I have a foreign name right constant Tim
kissing it's difficult for people and
you catch and pronounce and a lot of
these idiots who run around saying well
if you can't pronounce someone's name
you're racist right what happened one
time one of these guys uh
they'd just been making that argument on
the show and then they brought up an
article that I'd written and he'd
completely butchered my name
there you go and you could have used
that you could have gone hey hey this is
my chance yeah and I I just want you you
got my name wrong it's okay it happens
right but but the these tools these
standards of like Perfection now it's
like this is the thing that always
bothered me with comedies like part of
the process of discovering what an
offensive joke has to be like is going
too far and then pulling back right yes
you try it out it maybe goes a bit far
you rephrase it you reword it but if
every time now yeah that joke gets
recorded and put on the internet that
changes the way that the whole thing
happens right of course and and isn't
that the most polite way to do it let me
go to a comedy club see where the line
is and then I will now course correct
and not go there again or go over it
again yeah and then now I have the bit
down now I got it but you're just
getting mad at the at the part where you
went over to to figure out where it's at
and now you're mad at me for trying to
do the right thing in a weird way yeah
yeah Chris Rock made that point
um a few years ago where he was talking
about when he created you know when he
was fine-tuning the road team you know
black people versus the m word and he
said when I first started doing it it
was just outright racist almost and then
it took me six months before I could
make that bit funny but just imagine
we're in a place let's call it 2022 yeah
where you do that routine someone
records it puts it out on the internet
and goes you know Chris Rock is you know
punching down
yeah exactly
we never get to see that bit and that
bit you could argue legitimately change
comedy it's an amazing it's an iconic
bit I think about that joke twice a day
I like the N word yeah but yeah that's
an amazing bit and thank God he worked
it out and thank God it was in the 90s
yeah yeah
so we talked well we talked about this
stuff a lot um other than that I mean
you've been going a long time 16 years
like how what else has changed in the
comedy world what do you notice well one
thing I noticed uh was in New York New
York was like this Bastion okay was like
a thriving comedy scene and when I moved
here the alt scene as we called I don't
know if you guys have heard of this was
big it was like this kind of bring your
notepad up get out of the clubs that's
hacky or you call a guy in the front row
gay where'd you get that shirt well I'll
talk slower New Jersey you know a lot of
that and so they made this alternative
scene which was funny a little less mean
uh whatever a little wackier a little
strain more abstract and it was great it
was a lot of funny people Zach
Galifianakis and all these guys came out
of there Todd Berry and they could all
do clubs but this was just becoming this
kind of movement it got very popular now
the TV shows are picking it up Flight of
the Concords was pretty alty you know
stuff like that and
that was great because I was a new comic
who could show up and they were a little
more welcoming you know and it wasn't
like what is this a straight white male
who it was just it was just a comic and
ironically as we get more inclusive
those shows started to go away because
they started making these rules hey you
can't say this can't say it now there's
like two of them they used to be like
50. and it's just kind of a microcosm of
society like hey you gotta look like
this you got to be that way we have
rules now you can't do that and it just
they all just started going away one by
one and it was like this booming great
way to be a comic like these rooms would
fill up and they were it was like the
cool thing to do with these rooms and
now they're all gone basically wow and
that's it should be very telling
and nobody gives a [ __ ] because
everyone's like well I'm not starting
one and that's just how it goes and
that's that's what kills me it's like
Chappelle love them or hate him he puts
out that special the closer a lot of
trans material he's uh he's all on the
trans thing now
and this woman at Netflix big
transitioned dude to woman black guy
lady was like [ __ ] him he's a transfer
then people found her tweets and it was
like [ __ ] these [ __ ] and these Asian
people I'll kill an Asian [ __ ] f
word f word whatever uh and then you're
like okay well now attack her and they
didn't and you're like well why is he
bad and she's not she's saying worship
than him and on Twitter but they don't
attack her and that's when I get annoyed
because I'm like if you really believe
this [ __ ] you should be mad at her too
yeah but they think they think comedians
are powerful this is this is what they
think I guess so they think that because
you are on Netflix or because you're on
a podcast or because you're on Twitter
or whatever you have power this is the
idea that because people hear more
people hear what you have to say that
means you're you know you've got to be
responsible now it's like comedians like
no one is Mac comedians thinks comedians
but yeah it's it's it's crazy you're
right I guess but
Schultz said this like comedy is
supposed to be wrong like I just said I
love the n-word yeah I don't love the
n-word but that's funny because it's
such a ridiculous thing yeah I'm
supposed to say the wrong thing and then
people go he said he said he loves the
n-word and you're like what are you
doing yeah are you nuts and it's like
that old thing are you lying or are you
stupid which one is it yeah and I think
they're lying yeah do you see good
things about what's happening with
comedy is there anything you're excited
about well there's a lot of good Comics
nowadays yeah comedy's very popular and
it's uh moving tickets I mean I've been
doing this a while and it's we're in a
boom yeah sure really oh yeah oh yeah
yeah and uh
you can make your own way you have
YouTube as much as we [ __ ] yeah we're
doing something you guys are making your
own stuff I made my own special I put it
on YouTube and until YouTube starts
going hey we gotta get rid of this guy
we gotta get rid of that gal then I
think we're in a good place so it sucks
all the shitty stuff sucks but like my
friend just made a movie with a canceled
comedian and the movie's doing great and
I'm like so how's the backlight you're
gonna he's like we got a ton of it but
we just ignore it yeah and I think sadly
that's the key yeah and I hate that
because I try to be a nice guy I don't
want to be the offensive guy sure I mean
to anybody anything is offensive you do
a joke about a buzz saw well my wife was
killed by a buzzsaw it's like I didn't
know that sorry I wasn't trying to hurt
you so that's gonna happen it's
inevitable but
I don't want to be that guy like you
know these comments like I walked half
the room because I keep it real and
you're like oh yeah what are you crazy
I'd like to make people laugh and all
that so I try to cater my act and keep
it somewhat neutral and somewhat polite
I have trans jokes I have gay jokes I
have black jokes but they're all just
jokes about something it's not like mean
yeah I can get mean sure but I try to
keep it very on the level and then when
people still attack you you're like what
makes you just want to quit
hey Francis what do you think is the
best way to advertise a business that's
easy all you need to do is spend shed
loads of cash on an advert that's going
to be promoted on a dying medium-like TV
then simply sit back and watch all your
hard-earned money disappear down the
toilet what about advertising with
trigonometry why would I do that when I
can advertise on itv3 for the measly sum
of 20 grand and be watched by six people
because trigonometry now has over 350
000 subscribers across the different
platforms and gets two million views and
downloads a month that's right you can
place an advert with us and we'll
promote your brand on one of our
episodes your advert will be written by
two professional comedians yeah that's
right we're hiring two professional
comedians
when we make our ads funny and engaging
to the point where some people say the
ads are their favorite parts of the show
yeah we probably shouldn't admit that
mate all you need to do is contact us on
marketing
triggerpod.co.uk that's marketing a
triggerpod.co.uk advertise with us and
we'll get your business canceled
I I think the part of the thing is man
and obviously as Comics we're hyper
sensitive to it we're very sensitive
right we are but also it's like nowadays
if you like I I meet people I was doing
TV once and I met this woman uh she she
runs a charity for children and she
raises money for kids okay and she gets
[ __ ] on the internet
for watching what for man grooming uh I
I no no not grooming that's a that's
socially approved and sanctioned in the
UK especially by the BBC yeah exactly
but you know what I'm saying like yeah
yeah you can't get [ __ ] you can't it
doesn't matter anything you do now yeah
someone someone some there someone
somewhere is going to be doing that well
yeah somebody had a funny joke I can't
remember who but it was like I get all
these comments online they're so mean
then I looked up Beethoven's Fifth
Symphony and it's like this sucks [ __ ]
this guy he's a douche what a [ __ ] or
whatever and you're like
but here's what really kills me all we
preach is like
hey you got to get these people's
pronouns it's insensitive these people
have feelings and you're like yeah I get
it okay so I'll try to I'll try to adapt
I'll try to keep up with your
ever-changing system and I try to play
ball but you calling me horrible [ __ ]
why isn't that insensitive so they've
built this system where you're you have
carte blanche to be insanely cruel if we
deem you inappropriate but it's like you
deemed me you gotta let everyone deem me
that and that's what's [ __ ] up like
all you preach is insensitivity but
who's more insensitive than you calling
someone a bigot that's insanely like
that hurts my feelings you call me a
racist I'm not that's you're basically
calling me this ignorant stupid person
what's more incentive I got your pronoun
wrong on accident I'm a [ __ ] monster
you're a monster you're saying [ __ ] you
know I have my mom like somebody tweeted
your uh pedophile I'm like Jesus Christ
sorry Mom and she's like what the hell's
going on I'm like that's the internet
she's like this is crazy I'm like it's
fun seeing it from announce Outsider
yeah who's not involved in all this [ __ ]
and I'm like yeah I know it's it's
horrible but I'm
and she's like you're not bothered by
this I'm like I'm used to it yeah which
is even sadder yeah yeah so that [ __ ]
sucks like I don't think these people
realize how much damage they do to
people's psyche and you know just the
country yeah yeah have you had friends
who've kind of gone through that yes yes
and you know you you apologize so sorry
it's it's
I don't know what to do and like should
I defend you don't defend me then you'll
get you and they'll be mean to you and
you're like all right all right
so it's just sad it's like you don't
realize what you're doing but you were
racist I made a joke what are you crazy
I mean what Gillis went through is
traumatic yeah dramatic and they go he's
fine I'm like how do you know he's fine
he's selling tickets it's not about the
tickets it's about what you did to the
guy's life you had two years of his life
he was like having night terrors
depressed and where's the uh where's the
Sensitivity I keep hearing about you
know but you deemed him inappropriate so
therefore
carte blush
but but this is it you know it's like
the end of the play The Crucible you
know where he's being where they're
gonna execute him and he says and he
says
don't touch my name
leave my name out of this you know don't
tarnish my name my name is the only
thing that I have John Proctor's speech
at the end and it's so powerful because
it's true because really all that we
have in many ways is our reputation our
reputation as a human being and when
someone says the word racist or bigot
they're tarnishing your reputation yeah
yeah that's the plan you know and it's
to discredit you and ultimately it's
dehumanizing and these people don't seem
to understand that I know because
they're they're bubble they're they're a
hero and it's so sad because you're like
you're not and you don't get it and you
can shake their shoulders and they'll
they'll never understand you know and
and they have that agenda but also they
don't seem to understand or maybe they
do that when you do this to one person
it has an effect on everybody else
around them sure sure no but I think
that's the entire Point yeah the entire
point is to control how people speak
what people joke about it yes yeah
they're trying to shut down a lot it's
just trendy at this point too yeah even
if it's not about control which maybe it
is but it's just like this is the cool
way to be I'm I'm an activist or
whatever the hell they tell themselves
and you're like but you're you're cruel
yeah but you could say hey police are
cruel when they beat up a guy who
murdered somebody but they got to do it
that's the other ironic thing it's like
defund the police but this they're very
police-like you know hey don't say this
don't do that you got out of line we
gotta hit you over the head it's very
police-like
but that being the case
I actually think it's important
particularly with comedians particularly
when you know that they haven't done
anything wrong that if when people come
after them or people say [ __ ] we've got
it all stand up man right we've all got
to go look [ __ ] off yeah because the
more you push back against it the less
they're going to want to do it maybe
even ignoring is even more powerful
maybe it is I don't know I've just I'm
vengeful
you know what I mean yeah it's to me the
the they're no different than the
playground bully they're not gonna do it
to someone really who they know that
they can really hurt yeah because they
can try but they're gonna go after and
really try and hurt the people who they
know can't fight right right and and
here's the saddest part is we're in a
nice place talking about this a million
people are watching this go and maybe
not a million let's be realistic two
minutes
people are watching is going three white
guys sitting around talking about cancer
what the [ __ ] do they know about that
and you're like you're doing it again
you can't help yourself they're doing it
right now they're going three-way go
here we go we got to listen to this [ __ ]
again you're like
first of all maybe maybe listen Maybe
absorb something and take it in and
second of all
it's a it's a problem it's a thing like
people are losing jobs there's people in
cubicles who are like oh [ __ ] I said
this on a on a whatever and now I can't
have a job as a production assistant and
whatever the hell job it's like this
happens all over and you're like
stop focusing on our race too like three
white men straight away it's like
it's just so exhausting and you're like
just listen to me I'm a human being all
we talk about is like inclusive and
open-mindedness and that's the opposite
of that but it's also so superficial
because we we've talked about this in
gazillion times but Francis mother dark
brown skin woman from Venezuela okay
Latino right but he happens to look
white therefore he's a white man right
very well I'm a first generation Russian
Jewish immigrant with like Greek and
whatever blood right to a lot of people
I'm not white in the UK I wasn't
considered why in Russia when I was
growing no no right so you you you've
you've decided you know what my race is
you've decided he's a white man do you
see what I'm saying of course of course
because you didn't do that with gender
right yeah
no I thought you were my Jenner you
should do that with uh with your race
right so but but the whole idea that
whether what people are saying is
valuable and know it depends on what
skin color they have to me I know it
seems quite like quite a backward idea
Mark completely backwards and complete
regression and I it has to topple over
on itself because I saw a woman once
with a she was shouting there's no such
thing as gender it's a construct it's a
construct but she had a shirt on said
the future is female and I'm like
ah the irony what are you doing
by the way future is female not very
inclusive which is wiping out uh and I
look I know I'm reading into it too
literally but I'm a comedian yeah but uh
yeah it's just like it can't last
there's always these ways where it just
keeps contradicting yeah and
when it does fall over it might be in 10
years I'm going to remember every [ __ ]
guzzler piece of [ __ ] who is on the
other side yeah it's like they say the
future is female but none of them can
Define woman
ah yeah see that's another one you're
like yeah what what the [ __ ] yeah all
right man well we've done a lot of
bitching in this podcast
we're the ones that have been making it
happen yeah um what are you excited
about what were you looking forward to
with comedy with what you're working on
uh well I got a I got a fun hour in the
in the hopper it's like getting there I
give give it another six months this
will be really cooking and
clubs are full people are coming out
there's a hunger for comedy my immediate
social media is going up my YouTube is
going up so like people are finding the
funny people which is what it should be
it should be a meritocracy where the
funny wins yeah I don't care what skin
color gender whatever funny should win
and I think we're going in that
direction the cream seems to rise and uh
I'm excited about that I think it's good
I I hope the country I know you guys
aren't Americans but I I hope it can
figure itself out and it seems like the
people are talking and you read every
comment on [ __ ] and it's like oh I agree
with that I agree with that I agree with
that so I I feel like I'm in the
majority right uh every green one I go
to we have this conversation so really
oh yeah oh yeah so the comics are all
talking about this not all of them but
the ones in green rooms the ones working
[Laughter]
and again I don't want to be one of
these like hey we gotta stand up and
fight this woke [ __ ] like I I don't want
to be that guy but it's like hey if you
keep [ __ ] with people's [ __ ] it's
gonna happen we never wanted to be those
guys either we just like saw what was
happening in our industry and you've got
to remember in the UK it's a little bit
different because there's one industry
like here let's say you get I don't know
you whatever people get annoyed with you
in New York you can go to L.A you can go
to another scene right in the UK it's
not like that right you've got one scene
and if the [ __ ] four Gatekeepers that
control everything don't like you or
don't like the political side you take
or don't like the joke whatever that's
it right yeah so um what about YouTube
can you go to that well now so that's
the only way yeah right but most people
see this is what most people don't
understand though is uh in order to have
like a successful podcast or a YouTube
show it takes quite a lot of work yeah
we were taught in this business you'd be
funny they'll scoop you up they'll put
you on TV Bright Lights there you go
yeah yeah they do all the care we Comics
now learning how to edit learning how to
shoot what cameras are good how do I uh
Mike the guy like that's new yeah you
know we could barely Drive yeah well
exactly and you and you have to put in
the work and the effort to build it up
and look it if you start a podcast now
it's a hell of a lot harder than it was
five years ago there's so many now now
it's it's competitive it's difficult uh
you you know you like when we started
trigonometry we had like a borrowed
camera and like a phone in like in in
like a it looked like a seance
just like a black curtain with one light
and we weren't even facing the right way
and it was crap like you can't do that
now like if you're starting something
now you've gotta you gotta you've got to
have a good straight away it's got a
good it's got a sound right yeah you
know so but this is the thing is like
everyone has an opportunity now but you
have to put in the work and like you say
that's not how comedians get trained we
think you know you do the clubs you get
picked up by an agent you get on TV you
know and then and then you're then
you're you're gonna be fine that that
that isn't going to be the model for
almost anyone anymore right it just
isn't no you're right but I think Dark
Times lead to entrepreneurship yeah I
mean that's always been the case with
human history like Yeah The Great
Depression all this [ __ ] came out of it
you know all these inventions and
whatnot World War II yeah yeah exactly
so yeah it sucks and we gotta we gotta
do all this [ __ ] and learn stuff but I
think it's for the best I think it's
gonna it's a hump to get over and it is
a [ __ ] but once you do it you'll be
able to control everything you do you
will put out everything and not censor
and all that and I think it is for the
best and next you guys have a lot of
great equipment but I think next is an
air conditioning unit
it is very hot in here yeah yeah uh but
Mark listen it's been uh did you want to
add something no no no no
no
why didn't you touch me the first time
but no like I completely agree with
everything you say it the thing that I
know is I remember when I first started
a podcast this is way back in like 26 16
2017 and I noticed it was very
interesting it was the white Comics who
were very shy about saying that they
were on a podcast they were like I don't
know what you know I'm worried about
what people think about it maybe you
don't get this in America every time we
had a black guest on they're like yes
I'm gonna put it on all my [ __ ] songs
I'm gonna put it out there because and I
was thinking I was thinking why is that
and it was like oh because it comes from
hip-hop culture because at that time
when hip-hop started you know black
people were ostracized they were
excluded they were facing a great deal
of races and president of society so
they thought to ourselves [ __ ] it if
you're not going to give us the
opportunity we're going to create
ourselves which is how hip-hop started
right right yes so it was coming from
that and I remember looking at them
going yeah that's what you need to do
you got to accept that this ain't
working anymore yes this model that we
were all led to believe was going to be
or the way to do it when we started in
the mid to late noughties or even
earlier we've now got to think more like
independent entrepreneurs oh yeah and
just make the stuff that we want to make
and then put it out there you're
completely right and look at hip-hop
when that came out especially like
gangster rap Ice Cube and NWA all that
[ __ ] you know they were burning records
Nancy Reagan don't listen to this
parental advisory burning records and
CDs and you know they're saying [ __ ]
up [ __ ] they're saying shoot a cop [ __ ]
a [ __ ] I'll jizz in your eye whatever
the hell they're saying and it was oh
the stuff that all your jokes basically
yeah yeah exactly all the classics but
it was taboo and all that but like
how corny do those people look now rap
has flourished so much and we got great
artists and
the weird thing is like now when people
want to stomp out comedy or something
you're like
you want to be in the the annals of
History you want to be the the burning
Ice Cube records guy you know like can't
you see that this is the path you're on
and this I you get to be ice cube yeah
which is so much better you're an artist
you're a cool guy you're a talent and
then they go hey this is offensive and
inappropriate you're like that's the
side you want to be on when Elvis is
shaking his hips you want to be the and
they they just use different words they
go well you're offensive you're a racist
you're a bigot with the ice cube you're
a thug you're uh you know a criminal or
whatever and you're like
it's just a different version of the
same [ __ ] thing with Lenny Bruce
whatever rock and roll you know Elvis it
just keeps going and you're like can't
you see you're on the [ __ ] bad side
and this is it because when I was
watching the NWA film I can't remember
what it's called oh it's a great dog
yeah and it's a it's a brilliant movie
and when they were trying to shut them
down they came out and said this is my
right yeah as an American for the
Supreme Court this is my first amendment
right yes for free speech to say what I
think and what I believe and you're like
[ __ ] yes yeah that's how it should be of
course and look at history like you're
you're gonna be the Dork yeah if you
fight against that as time goes on like
people are like gay marriage is wrong
now we have gay marriage you want to be
that guy who's holding down
artists that's crazy yeah and then and
you know and the thing that I really
enjoyed from this conversation is is
this sense of optimism because I think
particularly in the UK where we're less
optimistic we we have less of that kind
of entrepreneurial Spirit it doesn't
come as easily to us there's more of a
kind of like oh [ __ ] what are we gonna
do yeah
it's all finished
there is that it's also because we have
laws that prevent you from making
offensive jokes yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's terrifying yeah but with America
what do you think of that like from an
American perspective so we have laws for
example that say that if you're grossly
offensive you can be you could the
police can call you up uh and arrest you
they can ask you like we had one guy
tweeted something offensive the police
called him and said we need to check
your thinking make sure and we had a
comic recently called Joe lyser uh who
he was she was on tour very popular
comic in the UK very much
he's not like a guy that's going out
there going on with this you know
offensive whatever and uh he had a visit
from the police or a call from the
police to explain his joke because an
audience member like what do you make of
that in America I think that's wild I
think it's I hope we never get there I
think that's insane I think it's scary I
think I know in Germany it's illegal to
make a holocaust joke which is funny
because whenever a German comes to new
to New York and they go to The Comedy
Cellar where are you from Germany uh
[ __ ] Nazi out here and we do it
immediately yeah it not only is it
allowed it's the first thing we say and
I they're like
I don't think they're mad we're calling
them a Nazi they're like Wow you went
there and that's what's great about
American Comedy it's like we're going
all in immediately and saying the worst
[ __ ] thing and breaking the ice back
to breaking the ice and I think that's a
good thing this guy can finally laugh at
this [ __ ] up [ __ ]
for the first time in how many decades
and that's [ __ ] awesome and look I'm
calling him a Nazi which is shitty but
he knows I'm joking you know he's at a
comedy club sitting next to a black lady
you know like we all know what it is and
that's a beautiful thing and why would
you want to take that Joy away
and what a perfect way to end the show
thank you so much for coming on the show
Mark Kyle Hitler
last question we always ask is uh it's
complete free hit what's the one thing
we're not talking about that we really
should be oh well I think when a lady is
blowing you work the balls no uh I feel
like the balls get neglected one thing I
think is very strange is my friend is a
funny comedian She's a Lesbian and
everybody now is like you know I'm bi
and maybe I'm gay you know I'm I think I
find women hot maybe I'm bi and she's so
mad about these people
using this as like some kind of prop and
like uh jump up a level in a career
thing because now I'm interesting I'm bi
and she's like you're not bi you're a
liar you're using my [ __ ] that I went
through Hell she's a little older she's
like using my [ __ ] to like prop yourself
up and I went through hell as a gay
woman who's in her late 40s early 50s
like
she's pissed and I don't think anybody's
bringing that up because we're too
scared to approach anything in that
world
lesbian lives matter exactly yes scissor
yeah exactly like you know you get
people go like I'm queer like like
blokes or whatever else you go unless
you've sucked the dick yeah do you know
what I mean of course of course then
shut the [ __ ] up basically shut the [ __ ]
up and uh stop using my [ __ ] to elevate
your success yeah there you go this
episode's ended well
I blow you right now
Mark we're going to ask you a couple of
questions from our supporters only but
thanks for coming on where should people
go and see you where they should where
should they find your podcast Etc tell
everybody where you're at you got it all
right my website is marknormancomedy.com
I'm all over the road in America uh tons
of tour dates I have two podcasts we
might be drunk and Tuesdays with stories
and uh yeah say hello follow me on the
internets and whatnot and just try to be
nice that's all I want is to be nice and
get along and and tell a joke and have
people laugh laugh and not hate me
fantastic thank you so much for coming
on and thank you for watching guys we've
got fantastic episodes that always come
out Wednesdays and Sundays 7 P.M UK time
uh our raw shows are again at 7 p.m UK
time and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast we're going to
ask some Mark some questions for our
locals only our locals supporters are
able to do take care and see you soon
who is the most annoying celebrity you
have worked with and why is it James
Corden
[Music]